all right it's time to come clean I kept
something from you in the last video I
didn't tell you about something that I
found but before you draw any
conclusions or answer in the comments I
just encourage you to watch the whole
video because in the middle of the video
you may be tempted to think you have it
all figured out but things come up that
complicate what is the simple answer
okay so there was an outlier I didn't
mention to you I didn't point out
because I just thought it was it was too
weird and it's refinery29 now you'll
notice that refinery29 unlike all of
these channels who are sort of more
well-known and even some of these like
WWE BuzzFeed they're all well known you
you might not have heard of refinery29
it's a modern woman's media company and
it got a lot of trending videos both in
terms of its size and in terms of how
many views it had to get to get on
trending now you can't see it because
like the axis is squished but there's a
big difference between what's even
Stephen Colbert had to get to get on
training then refinery29 did and it's so
different that it made me start to think
about you know why is this channel on
trending here is a great way to
visualize this made by each and le's on
twitter who used my data classification
to create a semi-log plot which all of
that is is it just shows scale a lot
better and here you can clearly see just
how different refinery29 is from any of
the other channels you can see it's a
total outlier in terms of how many views
it got to be trending that much like
just visually look at this if we take it
away the graph looks normal you add it
and it's like what is going on now if
that had been the only weird thing I
wouldn't be talking to you guys but
there was one other thing that I sort of
found by happenstance while creating a
time-lapse of this whole project that
made me think there was something else
going on and it's this so when you look
at the time lapse what you see is that
channels who trend a lot tend to get
those training videos over a pretty even
amount of time and that makes sense if
you're a very trendabl channel with a
very consistent upload schedule as a lot
of these traditional media companies
have you
you get training videos pretty
consistently you'll see you'll see that
a lot of these channels just continue to
grow through the end of our time lapse
that's not what you see with refinery29
now I'm gonna mark them so you can see
them and watch what happens they get all
their training videos right up front and
then just stop trending as if a switch
is flipped now I went back and I checked
their upload schedule their upload
schedule seems to remain constant their
view count remains pretty constant their
subscriber count was pretty constant
what could be going on here refinery29
seems to have been trending all the time
over a very narrow window about three
months and then it turns off the magic
turns off and I mean magic because they
trended 39 videos would you like to know
how many videos they uploaded during
that time 39 videos I was an 82 videos
one of two videos the refinery29 release
was trending during that time period and
that wasn't because every one of them
was a banger either the fact was is
their performance was really different
some videos got a hundred thousand views
when trending which is a whole thing
that's horrible already but some videos
got seven thousand views and went
trending and not like in one hour in
like one or two days seven thousand
views in one or two days and after
seeing this I've got to be honest with
you I was just left with the impression
that somebody was sitting at the
trending tab being like oh refinery29
uploaded another video I'm gonna pop
them on the trianing tab we're gonna pop
them on the trianing top pop them on the
training tab now of course the
explanation doesn't have to be someone
manually doing it in fact that's the
last conclusion I want to jump to but
that's just what it looks like hey like
I know
most people's thoughts when they see
this is just the algorithm change so
we're fine Derry 29 just isn't trending
anymore but the an algorithm change
would affect the all the channels right
like the in algorithm would change would
affect the signals that YouTube's
considering for every channel and when
we look at the plot of when all these
other channels are trending we see that
nobody else's training pattern changes
that drastically now the only
other thing that it could be and I would
love for you to date hit me up if this
is true it could have been a bug that
YouTube fixed we fixed the glitch that's
a plausible explanation the only thing
there is it's weird if it was a bug
because then they later make a think
piece about refinery29 where they ask
for friend retraining on how they grew
so fast that year and they say wow it's
incredible that you tripled your growth
over the last calendar year how'd you do
it and it's like well they trended 40
times in 39 times within a super narrow
window how do you think they did it like
you guys are the ones who trend them you
should know them and it seems
disingenuous to highlight a channel who
may have benefited from a bug in your
system so I don't know that's not really
that satisfying of an answer very
strange and I thought about not talking
about it but eventually so many people
reached out that I felt like I just in
the interest of completeness I had to
tell you guys something the weird stuff
too so that's it dammit dude I'm having
a panic attack I'm actually have another
cup of coffee